best friends since five went through
school together grew up together about
10 years ago my mom lost her dad so my
mom had a pot of money and Sue said to
her put it into something that's going
to get you a return she's doubled her
money if not tripled so I started doing
this for you four or five years ago and
I've gone sort of Full Circle so when I
was four or five years ago I was the one
wanting the money now I'm the dude
giving the money
so um yeah I went to UNI I was working
at McDonald's at the same time followed
that route because it was the route that
was I was told to do and then I came
across you and was just like I'm I'm
never going back to McDonald's it was
for rent but then when you sat down with
her when you guys turned up they
happened to mention it was also for sale
and you thought we'll break even at 30 I
don't have a dream board I have [ __ ]
nightmares 400 years before I knew
Elliot before I knew anything that you
do I was struggling to pay my rent and I
was doing it all on my own and every day
it was like
how am I even gonna afford to eat I must
I did think it was a little bit
hilarious when you lost your job
[Laughter]
so we've known each other for many many
years you've both bossed it in business
how much on average do you make each
month
our company on average around about 20K
20K you showed me 20 goes A bad month
and you're embarrassed at 20K
yeah
no 20K is okay 20K is okay so talk to me
about how you guys met and how you stole
her with my PA oh wow
um great story because you used to
massage my feet then yeah
why do I remember is that maybe you used
to bring me a bucket and wash my feet I
used to bring you a bucket of water for
you to put your feet in when you got off
stage but I did not
get in between the toes so you were
working as much as my yeah and feet
washer
um and and Elliot and Elliot
um met you at an event yeah and fell in
love and now I'm best man at the wedding
oh no well done so really about about
your backstory of how like everything
all started wow okay so backstory so
um crash course 2017. yeah deal selling
Master Class end of 2017 and then went
on to sell deals how many deals have you
sold to date 209 209 deals
bang and also you're doing lease options
yeah you've crushed to rent to rent
you're doing development deals and the
funny thing is you guys were the that
epitome both of you individually you
went to UNI talked to me about about
what happened so um yeah I went to UNI I
was working at McDonald's at the same
time and
kind of just followed that route because
it was the route that was
I was told to do I really want to do it
but did it anyway
um and then not long after I left uni I
came I came across you and started
working for years because you were the
you were the dramatic McDonald's worker
you know with the degree yeah you know
what I'm saying that you want to talk
about the people that go to UNI and
they're just doing drama or whatever I
think actually you didn't support
therapy sports therapy to be a perfect
foot massager no so so you went to UNI
got a degree and then um ended up at
McDonald's and what made you come and
apply to be work with me I've just had
enough
I had a good job at McDonald's but it
just wasn't because you were a manager
to be fair yeah but it just wasn't
enough like I I was just in a position
where I hated it I hated going I'd got
like a dog and it it just wasn't for me
anymore yeah
um and then I came across you and it was
just like I was really scared to take
the leap up first because McDonald's in
uni was all I ever knew I didn't know
anything else I was actually really
scared to to come to you and then
I think after about a week I was just
like I'm I'm never gonna invite to
McDonald's move City met earlier and
just everything changed yeah and also as
well I mean you're not my PA anymore now
you got with Elliott and that's just my
PA
so do you
know but a lot of people see you guys
because you come to the events yeah
um you help out and you you sometimes do
bits and Bobs on stage occasionally not
really so much but you know what what is
it what does an average day look like
for you guys like what are you doing
generally oh wow so we get it when we
finish sleeping usually which is quite
nice
um meetings 9 9 30 breakfast probably on
the phones in the morning to the
afternoon and then probably later on in
the afternoon probably four till seven
o'clock probably do we do our own stuff
do property stuff our days is just so
varied one day we could be on at one of
your events yeah sharing our story on
stage helping people get registered onto
the trading programs doing registration
I'll put seven eight o'clock in the
morning bed at midnight we love it or we
could be at home selling our own stuff
doing our own stuff
okay and then we sell our company
services which are what which are
um you know rent to rent lease options
lease options at the minute and you also
join you're at the events a lot and you
join Venture yeah a lot like you've just
done a talk to me about your latest deal
which is amazing yeah so and he came of
course
I came from
of course
really sweet girl she came she came up
to me really distressed really like not
she was struggling and so I just said
look this is what I'm looking for go and
find it she came back oh so she was
struggling financially so you basically
paid her to go and find you a deal yeah
yeah so she wanted to do the academy
right she quite got all the funds okay
so she came up to us and said but you
don't normally do that do you normally
you just work with Academy members yeah
you work at the back end events yeah but
on this occasion you felt sorry for her
I'm sorry for her
yeah yeah and she'd already in fact so
she'd invested to go to a training
program so she invested in herself so
I think that's what did it for me and so
the deal itself
um she called it we called it up
um
for a rent to run yeah and when we
phoned them they said are you looking to
rent out or to buy it and I was like oh
it's didn't realize it was for sale
um
there's no mortgage on the property so
she was trying to sorry she was trying
to get it for a rent to rent it was for
rent but then when you sat down with her
and you guys phoned up they happened to
mention it was also for sale and you
thought
of course it's a brilliant tip of
finding these options houses for sale
and for rent because that means that
they're happy to rent it they're happy
to sell it so maybe they'll rent it to
you with an agreement to sell it down
the line in which case lease option
agreement so anyway carry on so
um it was on the market for 145. so we
rang up
um and then they said are you looking to
rent or to buy it didn't realize it was
for sale
so it's on the market for 145.
we
put a proposal forward of renting it
often for four years with the option to
buy it in the future went and met the
owner very open to it
um they had had the property for the
last 40 50 years family
Cottage derelict Cottage they've done it
up to sell it and then with mortgage
um
yeah because even though they've not got
a mortgage on it if they're trying to
sell it most people would be buying it
to get a mortgage on it they'd need a
mortgage to buy it unless you're buying
it cash so people are struggling right
now and I think lease options are just
the perfect I think we're going we're
entering a time where lease options now
this is this is the time to get lease
options yeah not many properties to sell
in because the interest rates also
another thing that you guys know that's
so smart is because we're now in a
recession and we're entering a heavy
recession people can't afford to go on
holiday they can't afford to go to
Jamaica a Tenerife Barbados so instead
they do staycations and they get to
bridge law hopefully
and stay at your little pledge yeah so
what how much how much rent are you
paying the the landlord so we pay 600 a
month okay that sounds cheap yeah it's
like a little little cottage Originals
we're gonna break even so obviously
we're going to run it service
accommodation yeah and we'll break
how much profit you expected to make
about 1800
crazy that's just from that one and 800
Panama presumably you all the money that
you're making from you're going to say
put it into the box yeah and then do
what we're going to use it to buy it in
four years of course we normally don't
if you think about it if you're making
1800 pound a month for four years that
is assuming that are you confident
you'll make that profit yeah yeah I
think yeah all right let's do 1600.
that's that's nineteen thousand two
hundred a year times up by four at 76
Grand that means that in four years half
the money you get a little little small
mortgage
just banging what about the lady that
Sharif that brought it to you what did
you get in so we're funding it it's in
our company name yeah funding it we've
paid for the furniture we've put
everything up front
she we said to her we'll pay you a
finders for which is this is where she
got really smart with us we said we'll
pay you three we'll pay you two three
thousand pound fee she really wants to
quit a job that would have given her
enough salary for four weeks to go and
then you know set up her own deal
sourcing thing and be gone but she
didn't want that she wanted a percentage
of the profits of course
smart so we said okay when we've got all
our money back that we've put in so
Furnishing it and and putting all the
rent in yeah we've got all our money
back then we'll split the profits but
your book Shanice is managing it how
much are you going to give up 50 that's
generous bro it's very generous and it
sounds like you helped close the deal as
well yeah so you joint venture with
people come down to the events no we
don't what do you mean this is the first
one oh the first one we don't usually do
this what do you normally do we normally
do on our own and just pay people yeah
but you joined vegetarian with me on
Eagle work true we may not we mean in
this sort of scenario yeah so you should
usually we just give people friends and
then just step away yeah uh you just pay
people for they do that's what you do
Evans yes on the Financial Freedom
challenge where he was like I can't find
an investor and then you would just sat
there like what I'm kind of interested
yeah it's funny because we've gone we
obviously I started doing this with you
four or five years ago and I've gone
sort of Full Circle so I was four or
five years ago I was the one wanting the
money yeah I'm the dude giving the money
yeah and it's good why is that
I followed the training yeah no but
followed the process yeah you did but I
mean like why now are you still not
mainly focusing on
packaging and selling deals why are you
more interested in because you're
selling deals let's it's very active
yeah it's very active we don't want
active income I think our time is more
valuable yeah going to your Advanced 2
Network and being around that
environment and being around people
in this all of the time so we don't have
time to go and do 10 viewings a day to
go and negotiate on we'd rather just put
our time in to go into the events to
network to then just pay someone to do
it and then also we're we're joint
venturing and buying deals from your
students so we're supporting them by by
buying their first deal from them and
she's going to put a 50 into the academy
anyway yeah that's great and it's more
and also I know 50 is generous but like
we ain't gonna do a thing yeah but it
will help set it up and then we just
there's the keys and also like your
brother as well I know that you kind of
like utilize your family yes your mum's
also doing property yeah is your mom
doing property yet
normally on Wednesdays on a Wednesday
it's just like someone came did the
training no no thanks for free you guys
are friends you worked obviously for the
company for a long time we've been best
friends since the age of five so give me
the full back story okay best since
friends since five went through school
together grew up together you spend a
lot of time your house you spend a lot
of time mine your mom used to cut my
hair she was a hairdresser
um my mom are your mom best friends
right still are today they go for my mom
goes over to your mom's house for a wake
over they call it because they don't go
to sleep anyway about 10 years ago my
mom lost her dad
and we sold his house my granddad's
house and my mom had to add a pot of
money and Sue said to her mom said to
your word don't you know pissed up the
wall put it into something that's gonna
get you a return so they started doing
joint ventures together so my mom put a
load of money into the barn yeah the
Derbyshire yeah
um she's doubled her money if not
tripled
um and they're looking to do something
else again
so yeah amazing and when we met at five
um we weren't that academic oh God no so
I mean talk a little bit about the route
that you went down and yeah what route I
went down and yeah so I I left pretty
early didn't I I got moved to to Wales
when I was 12 13. yeah but we kept in
touch we left school I went and did my
Plumbing qualifications and my gas and
you went and did property training
programs with your paper I'm gonna yes
true story yeah so I thought it was
bizarre and as well you can probably
testify for this because I run training
programs um
but I wouldn't expect anyone to do what
I haven't done myself you and your moms
have spent thousands tens of thousands
and I remember like your mom and you and
all of our friends and family been like
what are you doing why are you going to
hold these courses but I'm thinking why
is it acceptable from why is it not
acceptable for me to go on a program to
learn about property investment from a
guy that's a multi-millionaire but it is
acceptable
to go to Sports Therapy University and
end up at McDonald's
very true very true everyone thinks you
know I'll be careful what are you doing
but he's like it doesn't make any sense
no and but you were one of those guys
probably saw what I was doing and we're
just a bit like yeah really I learned
the odd one what happened 2008 recession
came in I was I got my qualifications I
was plumbing and I got my redundant so
let go oh I must I did think it was a
little bit hilarious when you lost your
job I've never told you this
go on no I just thought because you were
like what are you doing going on these
courses but you were going to college to
be a plumber like after like a few years
I was doing all right I wasn't lucky to
be very all right
I just thought it was hilarious because
it's because it's like it's a hard
lesson but having a job is more risky
than having a business absolutely in a
way because if you've got a business you
can adapt make money if you've got a job
you can just they made redundant
you know so I felt bad for you and
everything like that and that's why I
invited you to go to California yeah
[Laughter]
you know what though when I asked you to
come to California you lost your job and
everything because I was like come out
we'll go out and I'll pay and all that
um you at the time I think you've got a
zero hours I was at Screwfix a Screwfix
yeah and you were like oh God I can't
get the time off work and I just thought
I'll be damned because I tell you
something this is this is God's honest
truth we were best 1985 right I didn't
know obviously at the time but when you
become successful young like I did by
the age of 21 I was a property
millionaire when your friends are all at
work
it's actually a bit lonely you know what
I'm saying like when
you you can do what you want when you
want with whoever you want but the
people that you want to be hanging with
are like I'm at work
kind of sucks that's what I offered to
pay for you to go to California and when
you told me
I can't because I can't get the time off
work and I'm thinking but you're on zero
hours contract that was when I was just
like
you need to sort your life out mate and
then obviously you came to the I'm
really grateful for the push what
happened
I came to your crash course
NEC Birmingham Hilton and this was
around about which is some years later
now 2017. yeah yeah five years ago and
then you came in the crash course you
wanted a discount on everything you did
the academy met Leah
stahlia conquered the academy and now
you're like one of the most successful
couples that we know man absolutely Kane
in it what would you say is the best
strategy for starting out later
if a deal sourcing or rent to run
because you obviously
um I mean you guys have been together a
few years now and you work on the
business together what would you say is
the biggest challenges of being like an
entrepreneur having your own company
because you have your own company now
you don't work as an employee for our
company obviously you still do stuff and
you contract work out it sounds you when
you come to the events I pay you pretty
handsomely because you help out you know
your crew you work as a training advisor
but you've got your own company you do
your deal selling your rent to rent you
come down so like
how did you transition Leah from an
employee to like a business owner and
how what changed what are the challenges
um
so anyway yeah which is why I pushed
myself to be promoted because I thought
if I'm at the top then I'm going to be
the person that's calling the shots to
start making all the decisions so when
it comes to starting a business I found
it quite easy because it was me making
the decisions
um my hardest part was when we decided
we were going to start doing it together
and and working out where we work the
best with each other and Elliot's
strengths and weaknesses against my
strengths and Witnesses I feel like we
found the perfect the perfect match now
I feel like you really you're really
good at certain things that I'm not so
good at and I'm really good at things
that you're not so good at but or even
when you become a manager when you're
employed often you have more crap to
deal with yeah as a manager and also tax
is like when you're an employer even
when you're working for us
you'd have to worry about it but also
you get covered because if you're if
you're an employee and you're making 30
grand a year you don't see 30 grand a
year because you pay tax first whereas
now you pay tax last yeah how do you how
do you handle taxes so we pay ourselves
twelve and a half thousand pounds a year
which is tax-free and each each yeah and
that's completely tax-free that's
completely why is it tax free who's
eating um 12 and a half Grand a year
tax-free anyone can do that with you if
you've got a self-employed okay okay and
then what about if you want to take more
than that because obviously that's not a
big salary of course so as business
owners we can take out what's called a
dividend if we need to so if we need a
bit of a buffer if we need a bit of
extra money we can take dividends out
and pay seven percent and also as a
business as business owners you can
climb a lot of stuff back on you yes
yeah so what sort of stuff do you climb
back as taxes a lot so we'd claim a
proportion of our rent because we run
our business from our home our car we
run our cars for our business so at home
do you do what I do is your dining table
not really a dining table it's a
boardroom of course is a board table and
the boardroom the table sits in the
boardroom not the dining room so you can
claim parts of your house back tax
deductible our Lounge is our office is
it yeah of course by the way this you
know
you've got a captain presumably of
course so everything has to go through
an account of course she's brilliant
yeah she's fantastic yeah so what are
your long-term goals what is it that
drives you in business
I was thinking about this on the way
down here you know some you know most
people have a bit a dream board yeah
have a holiday a car a nice house
I don't have a dream board I have
[ __ ] nightmares
and my nightmares no no eating me out my
nightmares oh that I am back in a job I
am back at Screwfix and they always real
as day and sometimes I wake up every
morning and I'm and I'm I think I've got
to go to work you pretend that you've
got to go back to work because I've had
that dream I've seen it I've felt it
what do you mean you're losing me bro so
you have a nightmare board I don't have
a knife he doesn't physically have a
knife
I don't get inspired by holidays cars
watches houses I get inspired by where
I've come from and and and and I've been
poor I've been
all right you know I've been all right
I've been well off I know what did you
say you are now
I I've never I you know my company is 20
grand a month yeah so you do pretty well
I'm doing very well you're very lucky
you pinch yourself Leah
yeah
yeah before I before before all of the
like to me it's a different
why are you
ever I knew anything that you do I was
struggling to pay my rent I was going to
UNI full-time and I was working
full-time and I was doing it all on my
own and every day it was like
how am I even gonna afford to eat like I
never had the
I never had any support from anything so
and to me it was like I am at the bottom
nothing can get any worse
[Music]
yeah so just so your nightmare board is
a case of it's not got my goal is I
don't ever want to have to go and get a
job ever again
you just want to be set for life yeah I
want to do what I'm doing now
every day what do you think about talk
to me about environment because
you're obviously around everybody that
you're around with now is winning even
Chris who used to go to school with his
women yeah
um you know all the folks might kilty
just look at your stagger Evans might
kilty Chris all the guys they're all on
the academy they're all absolutely
winning well that's a big reason why we
keep coming back to your events yeah
because we just love the environment we
love being around winners trust me it
helps environment is stronger than
willpower yeah I'd rather I wanna I like
being around winners do you not think
that that thinking I don't want to ever
go back to what life was like before you
focusing on the wrong thing a little bit
Maybe
because I have a lot of people say that
that are very successful they're like
say the the fact I think Kevin Hart says
this Kevin Hart says remembering what it
was like to be broke yeah keeps him
working even today yeah I have heard
that said before I find it a little bit
strange because I wouldn't want to focus
on the wrong thing but um I mean hey you
guys are killing it and you're around
good people you've got good friends
we're not really that material we're not
materialistic people I don't wear a
Rolex I don't go out and buy designer
clothes I don't go out and have fancy
holidays yeah my luxuries in life is
I've got a nice car we live in a nice
house and that's probably about it
you know we don't have expensive jewelry
what do you spend your money on or
invest your money in property so you
just continually back to the business
absolutely and obviously you do some big
deals at the moment so talk to me a
little bit about some of the deals that
we're doing together obviously we did a
big a big recent deal Eagle works over
Hampton yeah uh one million purchase
lease option yeah lease option again
lease option because lease option can be
on small residential and it can be also
for big developments as well yeah so we
bought it now they're doing it up yeah
um spending 3.6 yeah about that it's
gonna be worth six and a half yeah yeah
and then doing it into 48 Apartments
Mickey Mouse luxury apartment two
million profits two million profit when
you see prop deals like that though do
you not just think like how did we grow
up at school
rubbish at school and now when you see
like if you were to come to me at school
rewind 20 years you'd have come to me
give me a node just said hey Elliot in
20 years time
we're gonna be you know we're gonna
millionaire millionaires we were doing
five million yeah lots of derelict new
um art galleries in Wolverhampton not a
lot of laughed at you and I said go away
not me and you no Chad will be lucky if
we've been man yeah and now look at us
and you live as well what do your family
think about what you've done
at first they were a bit
unsure were they what were they show
about if it worked obviously it's not
it's not every day outside of kind of
going to training and meeting people in
this community that you know what rent
to rent is you know what deal packaging
is so very unsure
um but now
I mean my brother for example I would so
I've seen I've seen potential in him and
I would just talk to him all the time
I'd ring him up come to Simon's crash
course come do this come do this and he
was adamant he was having none of it he
came to our engagement party and you
were there the next day he was like I'm
not going back to work he came to the
crash course and now his life's
completely different
so good
the stories as well yeah we see every
day you've been with us a long time now
yes and yes like the amount of people
that come through the training
I'll get i'll get that's what fulfills
me when I'm sat down with someone doing
their interview for the academy and they
are literally there shaking and that's
not what you were like yeah like when I
was yeah you know James your yeah James
you all gave me every objection Under
the Sun the biggest one was yet to go
and speak to his wife
and he uh at the it took me three days
to get him to net at the event and a few
he needed to do it and I finally got him
and he's just completed on his fifth HMO
yeah he's plummeting his gas at the
business he's winding down he's done
with it yeah and I it's stories like
that that gets me that's why I love
coming to do what I do yeah because the
thing is with money is money is great
but like you said you're not I'm not
particularly materialistic either you're
not you guys aren't materialistic it's
more about money gives you choices to do
what you want there's no options that
you get in life yeah yeah you got kids
yeah spend a lot of time with the kids
yeah getting married I'm looking forward
to that how did you guys decide you
expect meant to be together what
happened
so Peterborough crash course 2019 yeah
so is that where you probably first met
yeah
at your event oh my goodness you bought
your new PA along yeah
so we went out for drinks load of us at
the end of the event we just got
chatting didn't we yeah
um I learned you know your family girl
you you you're into family you love your
family you want to get into property
um at the time you were doing quite well
in property I was doing well you already
doing a lot of deal selling yeah
great yeah so we just started we just
swapped numbers and went from there
didn't we um tell me about deal salad
what is it
Bill selling is you find a property
you package it up
in such a way that it's an investment
yeah you work out all the numbers you do
all the due diligence
um you then find an investor who's
looking to add to his portfolio and you
basically you put them in touch with you
marry them up and take them and take
effect you charge a fee up front yeah
and then you give them what a calling
off period hold the hand through it yeah
all I think now is the best time to be a
digital saucer ever
because the Market's dropping
it's a buyer's market right now yeah
yeah I agree six 12 months ago if you
were trying to be a deal so yes it was
very doable loads of
that yeah but every every property that
went up for the on the market 40 people
going to view it right
now probably goes up to Market and you
go I'm A supplier yeah I know it's on
for half
the Grand and they go all right come and
see it so all you need is access to a
cash buyer
it's got a lot of money if I ain't got
the time and you stand in the way and
get paid and you made freaking Fortune
doing that
and then lease option as well why didn't
you put on balance option I think it's
an incredible time for lease options the
market so
the one the one question that we've just
done it was on the market for since
probably March April well um didn't sell
didn't sell didn't sell and then with
all the interest rates have gone up now
it definitely ain't gonna sell yeah so
we just come along and said look we'll
rent it off you for four years and we'll
give you asking price but we'll give it
in four years time yeah hopefully by
then the war over in Ukraine would you
know come to an end and we might see a
bit a bit more normality and and it
hopefully it'll go up a bit in value as
well so then we'll gain well yeah
because even if properties are going to
dip over the next 12 months it don't
matter in even in 2008
the war going on there's interest rates
there's a lot of stuff which might be
making people afraid when people are
afraid property Market dips because
they're afraid but even 2008 the
property Market crashed but two years
later oh
so you we're getting these optional
agreement four five six seven yeah term
and even if they don't go up after that
long we can walk away but we've got the
option of the obligation exactly we
don't lose options yeah what is it that
drives you every day then despite you
apart from your nightmare board
for me it's it's creating a product that
people love so making the changes in in
the houses and and just getting getting
our product which is our service
combination units whatever
to to a standard that people love and
people enjoy going and just making
making a home for someone that's great
energy I love the way that you call your
properties your products because it is a
product this is a business your tenant
or your guest is your customer and even
when you're selling deals yeah it's
about treating people as a client
there's a what would you top to be in in
selling deals a top top tip would be
treat every client as if it was your
father your brother yeah as if they're a
family and don't sell a deal for the
sake of just selling it for a sake of a
two three thousand pound food yeah
because then you might get a quick deal
yeah talk well and good get finding a
quick deal and will it stack will it not
who cares we sell it get two three grand
it don't work
long term long term build relationships
with your clients because some of the
people that you're doing business with
now that you're buying deals off your
joint venturing with Etc you've known
them for years you know and it's about a
good relationship is always better than
a good deal well I appreciate your
relationship you guys and I'm glad to
see you smashing it what were your final
words of advice before we wrap up
final words of advice someone wanted to
get into property yeah just do it just
stop thinking about it and just do it
get off the fence
just do it just go all in burn the boats
and just just do it you can't go wrong
in prophecies they say you're safe as
ours is you can't go wrong it's only
ever gonna go up in value unlike Bitcoin
like everything else that everyone else
is trying
in the long term I mean a property is
not going to ever get voted nothing is
it no exactly even if it gets bombed
you've still got the land yeah which is
crazy how valuable even land is alone so
and you've got cash flow Capital
depreciation love it Leo you're amazing
thank you so much Elliot keep doing what
you're doing all right rock stars
[Music]